Democrats and other critics of President
Trump are urging former Starbucks
chairman and CEO Howard Schultz to
reconsider his potential plans for 2020
Schultz announced Sunday on 60 minutes
that he is seriously considering an
independent run for president in
response former New York City Mayor and
potential Democratic candidate Michael
Bloomberg issued a blunt statement
saying in 2020 the great likelihood is
that an independent would just split the
antitrump vote and end up reelecting the
president that's a risk I refuse to run
in 2016 and we can't afford to run it
now at an event for his new book last
night Schultz faced hecklers criticizing
his potential run I am seriously
considering running for president as a
centrist independent and I wanted to
clarify the word independent which I
view merely as a designation on the
ballot
[Music]
Schultz's book is called from the ground
up a journey to reimagine the promise of
America and Howard Schultz is joining us
at the table this morning good to see
you welcome glad to be here it's safe to
say that the response to even a
potential run as an independent has not
been muted what have you learned in the
past 48 hours have you changed your mind
in any way shape or form well I must be
doing something right to garner this
much attention in this most interest but
let's look at the facts the country and
American people are longing for and
deserve leadership that they can trust
in a government that is working for them
that clearly has not been the case and
what I have offered the American people
is simply an opportunity to hear my
story and to provide a opportunity for
the American people to say we don't have
to have two parties there can be another
choice and in doing so all 50 states not
just battleground states can matter for
the first time it seems like you have a
hurdle which is that there was a recent
Marist poll that said 57% of the country
would like to vote for somebody other
than Donald Trump yes before they can
hear the argument you just tried to make
they want to get over that hurdle which
is to say not have Donald Trump they see
you as an impediment
- that not as a furtherance of it but I
think it's a false narrative because I
think Republicans are looking for a home
and if Republicans have a choice between
a far-left liberal progressive candidate
on the Democratic side or President
Trump
President Trump is going to get
reelected if I can get in the race and I
only need 15% to be on the debate stage
I will provide the Republicans with a
choice that they do not they do not have
in addition to that I think we have a
situation which we must agree with I
mean every American is looking at the
fact that we have such toxicity you're
gonna have senator flake on the on in a
little while talk to him about what it's
like to be a centrist person and trying
to govern from the middle it's
impossible how would you compared
Democrats proposal to universal health
care akin to a border wall in 60 minutes
is that what you mean well you just
played senator Harris is saying she
wants to abolish the insurance industry
that's that's not correct that's not
American well what's next what what
industry are we going to abolish next
the coffee industry I mean the the
Republicans want to get rid of the
Affordable Care Act I don't agree with
that the Affordable Care Act should stay
and it should be refined but ii think we
should get rid of the insurance industry
again this is exactly the situation it's
it's far to extremes on both sides and
the silent majority of america does not
have a voice and that's the voice i
wouldn't have a winning message why not
have that debate within the democratic
party of which you were a member up
until recently because i would have to
be disingenuous to try and run as a
democrat there are millions of people in
america in the country who no longer
affiliate themselves with a democrat or
republican here's the facts 42% of the
american people today designate
themselves as a as a independent person
30% are registered and 12% affiliate
that's more than republicans and
democrats let's give them an opportunity
ovations for your running is addressing
the national debt yes we're seeing more
and more economist including the former
chief economist of the IMF recently say
that it's not a catastrophe that we can
deal with hide
why are they wrong why is this such a
priority for you well it's immoral for
both Democrats and Republicans who have
piled up twenty one and a half trillion
dollars of debt and now the Democrats
want to suggest programs that tally up
to forty trillion dollars what's immoral
is that that that debt is going to be on
the burden of our children if it's you
and our Grimm even if it's used for good
causes well there's no good cause to we
if the country cannot afford to have 21
and a half trillion dollars of debt on
its balance sheet when we need to
reinvest in an education system a health
care system create jobs fix immigration
and the fact is the government is not
providing common-sense solutions for the
majority of Americans let me ask you
this yeah somebody says boy he's gotten
a tough reception guy next to him says
or woman next one says yes but this is
Howard Schultz's big idea which is what
the big idea is very simple to unite the
country for us to come together to do
everything we can to realize that the
promise of America is for everyone but
every politician is going to say that
yeah but no politician and the
Republican and Democratic side can do it
because both parties are involved every
single day in revenge politics and can
you imagine what powerful signal it
would send to the Congress and to the
country if for the first time since
George Washington an independent person
could be elected president Howard you
know that the president is not elected
by popular vote yes it's an electoral
college yes you know the last
independent who won electoral college
vote was George Wallace yeah in 1968 the
the system is stacked against anybody
trying to run as an independent
what state could you get electoral votes
from winner-take-all primaries not only
is it stacked but the Republican the DNC
in the RNC or do everything humanly
possible to prevent an independent
person from running that's an American
that's not right but I could beat the
system can you well I think I can beat
the system if I decide to run we will be
on the ballot in every state all 50
states and this is so vitally important
in the last presidential elections the
only thing that mattered was about eight
states battleground states that define
the race if I enter the race
be in the ballot of every state in all
50 states everyone's vote everyone's
voice would matter it would be a 50
state race and I would be on the ballot
on the the debate stage with only 15%
polling all right we can get to 270
we're gonna have to end our race here
but the book is great and you tell a lot
of stories about growing up of course in
the projects and Brooklyn it's it's a
great story about how you built a
company from there on up yeah don't the
American people deserve more than what
we have right now we'll end it there
Thank You Howard Schultz from the ground
up is on sale now